so I'm making a game engine called hazel
and one of the best ways to actually
make a game engine to develop and add
new features to it is by making a game
because if you're not making a game then
you're not entirely sure what the next
step to making your engine should be do
I need this feature - I need that
feature instead of arbitrarily just
making a game engine which is probably
one of the worst ideas in this world by
the way for the record instead what you
could do is just simply try and make a
game and then you'll easily see what
features you're missing or features that
you would like to actually add to your
game mansion to make that game creation
a lot easier now hazel is the public
branch of hazel as it stands right now
is just barely an engine at all if you
just go to github right now and you
check out what is in the public
repository it's barely like a 2d
renderer with an event system and like
just some kind of basic application run
loop and some layers it doesn't have any
tools like an editor or anything like
that it's very very bare-bones no
scripting everything has to be done and
C++ all that kind of stuff now I have a
development branch that is way more
advanced it's got like in 3d renderer
and it's got like a tools around it and
all that stuff but what I'm gonna do
today is attempt to make a game in as
little time as possible using the public
version of hazel and specifically I'll
link the the buid or the commit ID of
hazel publicly that I'll be using so
that in the future you can look back and
see well this is what hazel was like at
this point in time for two reasons first
of all to prove that even though hazel
is extremely bare-bones you can still
definitely make a game with it and also
to see what on earth we need to add I
mean it's pretty clear to me what we
need to add like the rest of the engine
is barely done at all but in general it
should at least give us like a list of
actual bullet points if I want this
picture I want that feature on etc so
now we just need a quick game idea that
won't take us too long hang on what's
this video making a game in one hour one
hour okay so a few days ago this guy
called Danny uploaded a video of him
making
game in unity in one hour it's basically
like a little flappy bird clone if he
made this in one hour in unity I mean I
don't think we're gonna make it in one
hour and Hazel I'm gonna try my best
here but you know all seriousness I
think we should be able to make it in
hazel pretty quickly even though Hazel's
missing all these features I mean one
hour how hard could it be so the first
thing I actually want to do is look at
this video I'm going to take notes here
and see everything that we actually need
to do for this game and then I'm gonna
start a timer and I'm gonna try and make
this same game in my own engine and
hazel as fast as possible let's take a
look at this video
okay so Trello for task handling
it's an hour I'm just gonna use pen and
paper and in fact like I don't have any
time to spend at all on anything other
than literally probably writing half of
the engine okay well there's our first
little problem we can get that rocket
sprite into unity hazel handles textures
like I mean normally we don't have any
kind of physics engine okay so I guess
maybe we'll make spacebar control the
rocket by just kind of tilting it up and
giving it some kind of force there
obviously hazel without having any kind
of physics engine at all we're just
gonna have to add something really basic
I think it's probably reasonable to
assume that we can just recreate this
exact effect by just having like a
position and a velocity and then some
kind of gravity simulation and then you
know pressing and holding space bar just
adds to the positive Y velocity that's
honestly probably all we need nothing
like a wearing a the physics engine for
this ha the unity particle system I'll
just use the hazel particle system oh
wait so our particles is I mean
particles is gonna be probably one of
the biggest things I think so that well
that I've seen so far anyway in this
video because to have particles and I
mean there's a smoke particles they look
pretty simple derp we just have it looks
like we have smoke of varying sizes and
then it kind of grows over time it
rotates we might make a simplified
version of that we'll see how far we get
and then maybe
can tweak it later okay so that's the
first kind of example of collision
detection that was pretty easy there
that was just like you know colliding
two rectangles together that's easy to
do okay so random map generation that's
easy to do triangles don't think hazel
can actually draw triangles at the
moment and furthermore we also have the
additional problem of colliding with
triangles doing collision detection
between rectangles and triangles is a
little bit more involved than between
rectangles and rectangles so we're
probably gonna have to add some kind of
collision detection code to detect
collisions between a rectangle and a
triangle at this rate I think that we
can just well it's just flappy birds so
if the ship is at all if any of the
vertices of the ship is intersecting
inside the triangle if it's inside the
triangle we can just use a pretty simple
algorithm I think to basically detect
each of the four vertices being inside a
triangle if it's inside a triangle then
that's a collision and we can just set
the EMF of so I think that's pretty
simple we'll have to add that in there
of course we have no collision detection
or physics at all and hazel so he's
added a bunch of post-processing effects
what have I gotten myself into
okay so post-processing effects hazel
has none of that at all I mean honestly
I it looks like what he's got maybe I
even know if there's any press
processing effects here that I can see I
mean okay so he's got the okay the
colors dynamically change it looks like
it's kind of hard to tell but I think
that there might be of ever so subtle
gloww on the actual triangle on the
level basically it's kind of projecting
a little bit like that maybe I can't
tell they actually could just be the
vignette as if I have to make this
harder for myself let's just assume that
the triangles are glowing because I
think that's kind of cool I mean if that
was on in unities probably just done by
using like an HDR buffer and adding some
blue room we don't have that in hazel at
all and whilst I could add that in I
think that would be a little bit
cheating because I'd have to modify a
lot of engine code to make that happen
and then also I kind of think that I
should just be able to fake it basically
by just using a textured triangle that
has a bit of glory added to it in
Photoshop
okay so camera following player
displaying the score okay so you I we
don't have UI we can probably just fake
that with I'm GUI maybe by getting it to
draw directly to the screen buffer okay
so resetting and stuff okay here we go
there we go now there's definitely glow
on this I can definitely see Clos
happening on the triangles and there's
also a bit of a hue shift going on and
there's more particles with the flames
flames
okay so I'm just gonna say two things
that we're not gonna do it all or one
thing what I couldn't do it all was
audio there's just not gonna be any time
hazel this is a portfolio at all so he's
gonna kind of ignore audio as much as
that pains me because I love I love
music what I'm gonna do any music and
I'm gonna write any music and we're not
going to do any audio or sound effects
at all because that's just not gonna
happen it's just gonna be way too much
work and again way too much modifying
the engine code to make that happen so
that took him an hour
[Music]
and the games available on Android ok
well that's that's cross-platform
support also not happening
ok so let's summarize we have a
basically a flappy bird clone that in
itself is pretty easy to make we don't
really need to add anything to the
engine at all the biggest thing that is
important to the core mechanic though
cuz physics I mean the physics that he's
using is basically not physics at all I
mean there is a little bit of like a
ragdoll effect when it hits like like a
triangle and it's kind of like it's part
of the level it's game over it kind of
the ship just lies around but we'll just
skip that because who cares people are
gonna want to play the game again if
they lose probably instead of admire the
physics I hope so we can kind of skip
the physics but we do need some kind of
gravity and simulation therefore when we
actually interact with the rocket and
then collisions the other important
thing to the core game mechanic we
obviously need to be able to detect a
collision between the actual player ship
and the level terrain and then if that
obviously collides then we need to be
able to set the state to game over and
blah blah and restart again now
everything else in terms of features
that hazel does not support everything
else is kind of aesthetical don't get me
wrong we still gonna do them but the
biggest things there are gonna be the
particle system and then this kind of
bloom effect but the bloom effect is
just going to be I'm just going to
basically make that texture in Photoshop
and then apply that to a textured quad
in hazel and then we'll apply like a
huge shift effect as well to get that to
pulsate different colors like he had as
well so that's kind of the plan
I think the only other problem I can
think of is if we do in fact make the
triangle a textured quad then it's gonna
be a quad we need to be able to somehow
pinpoint the vertices within that quad
of the actual triangle like drawing so
that we can collide with it that's where
we're gonna be the most it's probably
gonna be the hardest part that I can
think of right now everything else
pretty straightforward writing a
particle system in like 20 minutes is
also gonna be a little bit of a
challenge but you know what let's just
see what we can do so I'm gonna start a
timer and then we're going to basically
see how long this actually takes alright
so the first thing that we need to do of
course is obtain the latest version of
hazel I'll have a link to this exact
commit this exact good in the
description below so that you can check
out what version of hazel I started with
I'm just gonna clone that into a
directory on my computer make sure of
course to do a clone recursive so that
you obtain all the sub modules as well
and now let's just try and build
projects and run it so that we can see
what our starting point is at this stage
hazel just kind of has this little like
sandbox of just some textures who we
were doing from previous episodes we're
just gonna take that strip everything
out make our own game layer and that'll
kind of be our starting point for this
game so the first real thing that I'm
going to do is set up my camera so
unlike Unity where you can just resize
the window and everything will be the
best in hazel at the moment everything's
kind of done manually so you have to
actually catch a resize event and then
resize the camera to like the right
aspect ratio so that nothing's stretched
so I'm setting that up right now so that
I don't have to worry about it in the
future it's just a simple orthographic
camera and I've just arbitrarily chosen
my total width to be 20 units okay so
with the camera set up I think the next
step is going to be decreasing kind of
level and player so if we talk about the
architecture just a little bit I mean we
don't have any kind of entity component
system or components or any like that
literally we're now to make some kind of
play a class to contain all of the data
and logic for the actual player because
we're gonna have to like do the controls
and the collision and you know the
assets to do with the player such as the
texture which is the rocket ship but
then we also are gonna have to have some
kind of level container I guess which
contains both the player and then all of
the actual triangles that make up the
terrain because having some kind of
class that contains that means we can
obviously access that data to do stuff
like collision detection as well as
render everything we'll have to randomly
generate all of that level as well so
that'll all come from the level class so
in other words game layer will have a
level and level will have a player and
that's kind of the hierarchy I'm
thinking of right now so I'm just
putting together those classes now
adding a position and a velocity for the
player and just a bunch of functions
that I'll call from game layer and with
that basic skeleton setup it's time to
open up Photoshop and take a look at
this ship texture looks like a really
simple texture
maybe like about 16 by 16 I'm just gonna
copy it directly in the interest of time
and of course trying to replicate I
guess what he's made there as well I
made mine a tiny bit shorter and of
course I added that channel logo in
there so that it's legit and now taking
a look at that in hazel after removing
this weird tiling thing that was in the
shader we have our ship now we just need
to make sure that we render our pod at
the correct aspect ratio because our
ship texture is of course not square and
there we go let's try and hook in some
input here so I'm just making this space
bar basically increase the vertical
velocity and after some tweaking we have
some nice quote unquote physics it was
really nice to use I am doing here to
help tweak these values and now we run
into our first real problem with the
engine we need to be able to draw a
rotated quad but we can't apply any kind
of rotation to the causes that we draw
textured or not that's obviously going
to be a problem because we want our ship
to rotate up and down depending on its
vertical velocity so I'm kind of
cheating here and quickly adding in
another draw quad function which will
also apply a rotation to the quad now we
have perfect rotor wall that's looks
really weird oh yeah that's right we
need to convert it to radians and so
with a bit more tweaking we have a much
better result now tweaking is really
gonna be the killer here I think if you
continually just spend all of his time
tweaking values which is really where
the majority at the time to make such a
game is probably going to go we're gonna
get nowhere so I'm gonna accelerate past
this so the next step is gonna be to add
in some terrain and I also want to make
sure that I have that top and bottom
boundary I'm just gonna use quads for
now to just make sure that I have that
continual generation working obviously I
don't want to generate an infinite
amount of quads all I want to do here is
basically have about five I've chosen
and then simply reuse those old ones
again once the ship has advanced far
enough forward all right and I was
looking pretty good now let's replace
them with triangles now as mentioned
earlier we do want to eventually achieve
that glow effect so because of that I'm
not gonna add any kind of triangle
rendering to hazel I'm actually still
gonna render it as a quad but I'm gonna
make it a textured quad and for now my
texture is just gonna be a simple white
triangle but eventually the plan is to
add a glow effect to it and after fixing
up some bland
issues that we encountered as a result
of the rendering order our game looks
like this if only those triangles were a
little bit more random I hear you say
well don't worry we're just gonna head
over to Stack Overflow and generate some
random numbers in C++ I've just written
a really basic random class because I
know that I'm gonna want to reuse this
throughout the game that's another great
feature that game engine should have of
course is a random number generator
anyway after giving it a quick test
we're ready to move on just adding some
really simple randomization to these
triangles gives us a really nice effect
here and now it's time for us to work on
the thing that I've been putting off the
thing that I'm bound to hate most in
this entire process and that is the
collision detection now what we have
here the basic collision ignoring the
kind of top and bottom because that's
super easy is between a rectangle and a
triangle now we don't need to know like
which side it collided with or react
like in a physically based way or
anything like that all we really need to
do is just take the rectangle the cord
that makes up our player take each
vertex and see if any of those vertices
are inside any of the triangles on the
screen and if they are then that's it
there's a collision we can just say
collision equals true game over equals
true and basically just that that's just
it
the other thing that makes this
especially complicated is that we're not
actually rendering triangles we're
rendering quads with like a triangle
kind of texture with this padding on the
outside the reason we're doing that of
course is so that we can add in that
glow effect eventually now the problem
is that we are interested in the actual
triangle vertices within that texture so
we need to kind of manually look at that
actual texture and see how far inward
those vertices actually lie so in this
case I've just used photoshop and
photoshop sulles to measure every vertex
there being exactly 10% into the texture
so what I can do is just basically
manually offset that vertex of every
triangle by 0.1 and that's possible of
course because every court in Hazel is
just one by one unit so an offset of 0.1
translates to 10% so then what I've done
here is basically just taking all of
those vertices and transform them based
on the transformation matrix of the
player and all the triangles and then
the eye
is to just check whether or not any of
the player vertices lie within any of
the triangles every single frame which
might seem really inefficient but to be
honest there's only ten total triangles
at any given time and the player is only
four vertices so it should be absolutely
fine and then just to check to make sure
that I've done everything correctly I'm
just rendering all of the vertices here
as red quads okay so now back to Stack
Overflow to see if we can find a little
algorithm or really just an equation
that will help us to turn whether or not
a given point is inside a triangle and
once we've got that it's just a matter
of seeing whether or not any of those
player vertices are inside a triangle
and then what I'm doing here is just
rendering this red quad if there's a
collision and that's basically it after
adding some basic logic to just reset
everything if there is a collision our
core game is basically done actually
hang on wait a minute we also need to
know what the player's score is but
that's really just a function of the
player's x position let's try and kind
of insert this into I am GUI somehow so
that we can get our score rendering
since we have absolutely no UI in hazel
as well as getting the camera to follow
the player and now we're truly done
here's some amazing gameplay from what
we were able to achieve in hazel okay
there we go now two seconds an hour two
minutes and 58 seconds so right about an
hour and that's what I've managed to
achieve inside hazel so not much I know
but we've got the kind of cool loop the
cool game mechanic going the other the
other stuff that we actually need to add
is mostly just things like particles and
the glow effect and the hue shift and
stuff that isn't really that important
to core gameplay also the gameplay loop
and all of that but I think that in
general if we just reflect upon this
specific hour and where I spent most of
that I think that a lot of it was to do
with the fact that there is no actual
GUI kind of level editor within hazel so
everything had to kind of be done
through code I had to just play around
with numbers a lot and tweak values a
lot by actually restarting things I'm
doing differently helps with that
because I was able to live edit values
instead of having to continually
recompile the C++ code but in general it
would have been way easier if I could
just kind of place things around
visually the other thing was the
collision detection implementing the
collision detection
was I don't know probably spent like 15
minutes or 20 minutes out of the hour on
that that was pretty that was quite huge
so anyway that kind of stuff is
definitely stuff that I would expect to
add to hazel in the future also having
maybe like a scripting language would be
quite useful instead of just using C++
for everything but of course that is
within the plan it just hasn't been done
yet so that's it done our two minutes
kind of not satisfying though is it I
mean he had like glowing triangles and
and particles and smoke and fire
particles I think it's only gonna be
fair if we kind of just screw the one
hour and we keep going with this and we
see how long it would actually take to
add in a bit of a particle system and
get those triangles glowing so the first
thing that I want to add here is a huge
shift effect to all of the triangles now
the default texture shader in hazel
actually does support color tinting
however we have no render a 2d API to do
that so I'm just quickly adding that
here and you can see that we've managed
to turn all of the top triangles red now
in order to actually cycle through all
of the hues for our triangles we need
some kind of HSV to RGB conversion
because we still need to actually send
an RGB color to the shader so I'm just
grabbing one here and now once we've got
some kind of color pulsing I want to
apply that to the top and bottom with
that done the next step is gonna be to
add that glow effect to the triangle in
Photoshop I'm simply going to go into
the blending options and just add an
outer glow effect and kind of tweak that
until I get it to the point that I'm
happy with it and after replacing our
original triangle texture with this new
glow one from Photoshop we get this
effect which is looking pretty good now
in Danny's version it looks like maybe
he added a light immunity so that was
kind of this smooth fall-off basically
like a little vignette it's pretty easy
for us to add that across everything
that gets rendered we can simply
calculate the distance from the current
pixel in the fragment shader to the
center of the screen and then just
multiply that in best result with our
final output color we can also tweak
that a little bit and add a smoother
fall-off using a square root all right
and now it's the part that you've all
been waiting for and that I have
basically probably not been waiting for
at all and that is the particle system
let's quickly write a particle system
now honestly speaking a particle system
is not particularly challenging to write
at all if you know how they work and the
basic concept
find a particle system it's dead easy
now I had a lot of constraints here not
just time but also the fact that at the
moment hazel has absolutely no batching
at all which means that every single
quad is rendered as a separate draw call
with that kind of system it's extremely
limiting how many particles you can have
on the screen because your calls are
rather expensive I said the pool here
the maximum particle pool size to be
1000 in fact that was just that pulled
the constant pool size which means that
they can never be more than 1000
particles on the screen at one time
otherwise they'll simply get reused so
we should never go above a thousand draw
calls which should be okay for most GPUs
I mean honestly I think that I was able
to get a pretty good result with not
much code of course this is not like the
best most efficient way to write a
particle system at all for example I'm
using an array of structures instead of
structure of arrays but that's besides
the point I mean come on i wrote a
particle system in like half an hour and
with our lovely kind of passive smoke
particles out of the way let's take a
look at those engine flames I went to
color picker comb here to just pick some
colors that I felt were nice looking and
I mean it's hard not to tweak this too
much because honestly you could just you
could just play around with this like
forever so eventually I just had to kind
of stop and then the other thing that I
did was actually make the particles emit
from the ship's engine in the bottom
then honestly I'm quite happy with the
result and I think this was the most fun
thing that I did in this entire game and
finally just to polish everything off I
wanted to change the UI font to open
sans I just got that from github and
also add some basic game state and a UI
like click to start and that's it here
we have the finished game okay so with
the game completed let's talk a little
bit about what happened and I just
realized that I didn't actually continue
the timer so nice so that took an hour
in 10 minutes roughly it's hard to kind
of keep track of it and I did have to go
up and get some water and stuff so we'll
just we'll say about two and a half
hours two hours 10 minutes maybe is how
long that whole thing took just in case
you're interested so I don't really want
to have too much of a debrief here
because I mean I just just gone out this
for like two and a half hours and I'm
really tired but I think it kind of went
okay I mean we were able to actually
complete the game within it I would say
a reasonable time Pierre
especially considering we had to like
you know write our own particle system I
realized I haven't talked too much about
all of the code in detail just because
of time constraints really I'll have a
link in the description below like it
github link to all the source code for
this version of flappy bird that I've
written in case you guys want to check
it out if you want to see a more
in-depth look kind of like almost line
by line at the actual code and how it
all works and maybe how I would do it
properly and you just want to hear more
discussion on that let me know leave a
comment below and I might make a video
kind of dissecting what I've written
here and how both how I think it what
hazel should have to improve this but
also how I've actually managed to kind
of achieve all the stuff that I've done
within these kind of two and a half
hours they'll also be a link in the
description below to Danny's original
video where I made the game in one hour
using community anyway I'm pretty much
done here to be honest oh never again I
think it's been super useful to actually
take a look at all of this stuff because
coming away from this I have a little
bit of a more of an understanding as to
like the kind of urgent features that
hazel actually needs to be in order even
to make small games so I'm definitely
gonna spend some time probably triaging
them and thinking about how we can
implement them into the game engine
series if you guys are interested in
that I do have a game engine series in
which I'm developing this hazel engine
from scratch episode 1 is literally just
the beginning of the project with
nothing there at all and the latest
episode at the time of me making this
video at least is the actual actually
hazel of the state that I used it in
today to make this game so if you're
interested in that definitely check that
out I'll have a link in the in the
description to the playlist it's just
the train home slash engine for short if
you guys might help support the game
engine series and hazel and all the
videos that I make here on this channel
check out patreon account for slash the
channel will be a link in description
and let me know if you want to see more
of these kinds of videos I really
enjoyed making this I will see you guys
next time
good bye
[Music]